pree 5000 today we give in charity
fasting Ramadan Hajj is a pilgrimage we
see there's no god but allah and
muhammad is his final messenger the ones
I mean no it's a sacrifice but it's a
small price to pay for all the rewards
will get me from my love
they wanna know about Islam
so I want a comment when to my brothers
and sisters and welcome to the house the
hosting so anyway so basic just get
straight to the Punisher layer so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna watch a
video about Bubba fouseytube who
actually took a Shahada very recently
and on this video he's with Adam Sally
and inshallah just just to make things
very clear so as a disclaimer yeah
nobody's perfect guy to school when we
see our streams and what we say what why
would you not say that we're better than
them well my Allah guides will be lights
of the so anything that we say we do not
say out of arrogance or rise
self-righteousness but it's just an
advice to them and torso so just to make
something clear we are not in any way
shape or form what's that word oh that's
it inducing yeah we're not endorsing in
a way and we see this of humbleness
because there's some things I promise
you that we disagree with so we don't
wanna make it seem like we endorse in
the action is mashaallah and but anyways
let's get straight to the controller so
this video we're gonna watch and
understand where he is coming from Shana
in life when you have a vision for
something the reason they tell you
increasing J Cole said if they don't
know your dream yeah then they can't
shoot them down because the way we are
built as people if we announce our
dreams
human nature is set out to hate on them
so J Cole saying protect you dreams he's
not saying don't tell the world your
dreams that's not how the universe works
he's saying
if you announce your dreams and your
vision you're announcing a reality they
can't conceive in their consciousness
yet so when I'm talking about a world
that has world peace I see my home
country I see sharing common land is
that we trust those who why I say I see
Trump being able to look mean I'm saying
you know what I love you
humans first if they saw because I have
clips of us in Australia when I'm going
crazy or in LA when I'm wearing with
nothing but a towel telling you guys
that's what's gonna happen
yeah if they saw that yeah that's when
they're gonna call me crazy that's why I
don't show them that
until the Staples Center night you guys
want to see crazy
Alyssa pannacotta makes no mistake no
mistake she's going to do things in your
life I left I left yeah the reason I
left and I lost my faith was because
growing up in a really nice family my
dad is not religious my mom she wears a
javelin
my older brother he's very religious I
got set up in a dynamic where it was
forced to me and I didn't get to
understand you were told to do something
but you know explain why you just don't
do as you say and this is the reason why
sadly we do have people who leave the
religion why because they've been taught
to do something they don't understand
and when they are we may come across the
self-doubt and Shabbat they
automatically think okay I don't even
believe it fully now you've just see the
thing is we focused on them outward
aspects of Islam can you do this don't
do this where this don't we this but
there's no explanation of why there's no
high objective or higher purpose as to
understanding any what is Islam to us
what does a large sponsor I want from us
and why does why what cause they know
well I just think that one of the
misconceptions that people do sometimes
happens but they they use this argument
to say it out well my parents business
of my no it's true that that can be the
case the reality sometimes but you also
have to look at the indirect influences
that have caused you to be who you are
today
for instance you decide the society and
its expectations the society in which
you live in and the expectations of that
society has socialized you to be and
think in a certain way certain things
that you're saying now like I was
watching where you were saying about
dreams and all these kind of things and
peace and all of these these are all
symbolic or they're a result of
socialization to post of socialization
so you're not the way you are just
because your parents tell you to be like
them you are kulu-manali Eulalie but on
the Descent to do this you know okay the
parents you know might be blamed for
that but also it's a society and that's
enough that's exactly what we try to do
because we try to deconstruct those
false ideas as we constructed with
proper truth yeah you know and they said
and what are the things because we need
to understand is that society from these
things that you that's why you come in
with the way you think and be it for
example whatever give you ideas you're
coming could you get it this is what
you've been taught you'll be nurtured
weave so it's not just your parents and
I wasn't able to go to my mom and say
your mom the same way that you're
promising me that our religion is
correct what about this mother to her
religion to her kid his mother to her
kid who's to say who's right and was
wrong she said when you feel it in your
heart is when you know she's that go
study other religion go read go
understand and it's what enters your
heart
I left religion entirely I have tattoos
I'm not a perfect person by any means
but so yes gonna be powerful right here
so I'm learning that everything that has
been happening to me good and bad the
bomb threat
I'm did allowed the next morning when it
first happened I pried it I said you do
this to me yeah you promised me I
thought in my prayers but I realized
that's what I wanted he gave me what I
needed but just nap that's so powerful
do you see what he said that because I
didn't give me what I wanted
he gave me what I needed and this is a
very big issue because you know what the
long says it's always because we live in
a society we want immediate if I want
something I want it now yeah we live in
a fast life fast cars fast food
everything is just
I want something boom I get Amazon Prime
boom all of something's going to be a
next thing we live in a society where
one thing immediately desires it's just
become Oh suddenly hey what he said is
very profound because the young so this
is exactly what the youngsters go from
do you can say I want this I want this I
want this but the whole point of Islam
is to what makes us different to in the
Angels the angels do as they are told
the animals do with what their instincts
do what the istic get caused them to do
here ok why if and this is things I
think we mention three or I think chef
mahmoud mission today is that if you
want to be better than the Angels yes if
you want to if you if you if you want to
be like animals you act on your decides
you you like it take before but you want
to be better than the Angels there was
just a rock I remember Sony better than
the Angels
I can remember yeah but in a nutshell
what it is is that we need to understand
that look it's not what we want but what
we need that's really important so he
knows exactly what every person needs
and this is exactly our belief as
Muslims in our belief in the puddle that
we believe in predestination we believe
that everything will come to in
everything for the believer as many some
said everything been a stranger
wonderful is the fear of the believer
his whole affair is good for him with a
thicker religion well he's done he let
me move man this is only for the
believer and if a badness comes to him
then he has several points we can occur
in Latin is good for him if something
good happens to him that's good for ya
and that's if you want to be better than
the Angels if the angels are told to do
something you do it that's gonna say and
when we ask for do what this is really
really important you know this is very
important this actually connects my
documentary
because it's a matter of not what you
want because you think that's good for
you and it's not it's what you use it
Allah Allah give me someone that's going
to be good for me because I lose a lot
people cook Allah give me somebody in us
like this and looks like to another but
they're no good for you that's what you
think we meet coming up soon and you
know this one just just the idea like
one of the things you've said is that
while he was gone doing his discovery
yeah he stepped outside the box to kind
of see everything hmm and there's a
beautiful discussion of my know is that
he was talking about the Fatah and he
was talking about that the the fact that
we don't actually need to come out also
I slam in order to cover it because the
truth is what is the photographer's the
idea that you're born upon a
predisposition to believe and worship in
the Creator the sustainer the maintainer
the one Allah so every human being on
the face of the earth knows naturally
who Allah is and what relationship and
he made them testify
let's to be Arabic my man I do Lord and
they all said yes we do witness you are
Lord we have witnessed this and this is
the fifth one there's most of them for
seen on the school especially I
mentioned that's the beautiful thing so
what one shouldn't fall into the trap of
believing is that one has to leave Islam
in order to rediscover it you can
rediscover the tenants of Islam by on by
clearing up your fitrah by coming back
to the belief that you originally have
anybody what when you were born and by
the way there are studies that have been
done on this like very commonly stated
studies in 2011 is a study in that
Oxford anthropological society they done
a study on the children basically was it
was a regional study across regional
study a lot of millions put into it
multidisciplinary and study like proper
study and they found that children are
asleep born with the innate belief
so it's not just a it's not just a
religious theory is something which can
be substantiated with just to argue that
point you're basically saying that you
don't have to leave this number you
cannot argue the point there's someone
outside okay understand it's time in the
first pizza to leave it when we say
Islam okay this is so Islam when we say
is the world we're saying that they
believed and had an understanding of who
God was all right we're not saying
babies are born with believing the
Prophet Mohammad's or the five pillars
of Islam one-sixth of a man we're not
saying this we're saying people have an
innate predisposition to believe in a
creator yes yes that's what it is and so
what Islam is the Quran is is dick so
it's just reminding the human being of
their innate predisposition it just
reminds the human being of the United
State in fact you cannot say not only
the Quran it's the messages in totality
yes they were sent to you to bring the
FitPro back the people so it is sweetie
where's nature's suede away from the
pond the message of the original
position oh I'm able to back away leave
you to we get my mmm strong in my face
when I get myself drunk in my love
strong for my friend one family and not
only that yesterday was the first time I
was able to walk into a message again
and pray with all my tattoos
understanding that it's not about I used
to be scared to go because of the
judgment you see this is another for you
if you make the message you know that
somebody says Damon if I went to the pub
and I spill my drink he was here go
another one free from the table you go
through the Machine you make one figure
get out so some how do you expect people
to love the house of Allah when you
making it so muggy to them so you know
I'm saying you know just believe in
allah subhanaw taala
and this is a thing because of the sins
of a planet of everyone being false is
it makes mistakes and those best to make
mistakes are those who repent and the
loss of our ties in the Quran yeah yeah
I bet the Liddy Nassif what do you have
any laziness of all I'm in the lieth
religion so allah basically o my slaves
who have transgressed against themselves
ie with sin do not despair from the
mercy of Allah because Allah forgives
all of the sins so to believe that Allah
spanner Allah will have mercy on you is
a big listen it's a biggest thing they
probably committed that the sin whatever
is it because in effect of the Holly me
a lot of Muslim has in his appearance
the theological text of possibility
a321s from the early scholars he
mentions what yes he mentions that
complete despair from the merciful Allah
can actually take one of the folders
enough Wow
really yes complete despair from the
mercy of Allah that's not coupled with
any type of hope yeah so just a bit
afraid that so if you believe yourself
allow enough to give me your fall into
big sins you negate in one of the
attributes of Allah he's the most
merciful you are you to come with your
limited mind and say you don't know
you're not going to forgive my literacy
I think the problem here is conveying
that to the people I got scared of Islam
because of how the Muslims treated me
because of what I was doing instead of
seeing me do something understanding
he's on his path let him find his way
that's not for our decision but I'm
gonna pray with him in silence and if I
want to give him a private I couldn't do
that yes they did that for example you
have a go at somebody you start calling
baby star no way yeah and there's
actually people that accept certain
misconceptions cuz we did thousand
videos about Adam solid with certain
things that he did with ruffles issued
with actually I've been giving them
advice that for the past two three years
as well I don't maybes wash story as I
watched it but the issue there's a thin
line if somebody's doing something of
course you should give them the senior
of course is part of our religion we
should
best for him you should not think oka is
going down and I've seen a lot people
calling in so many days when my first
casting and what lights it's sad you
push people further away however we
should not confuse that with for example
I'm gonna get sugar brother items in the
video here he came to the UK needed
certain things yeah which was wrong
because you publicly did it and only
that use promoting it now our concern is
the youth that's following you you can
see so let's look at that confused with
if we came out cuz we never calling him
name this I know we just have enough of
an Adam what are you doing is wrong et
cetera we should find that balance cuz
if we call everything criticism I mean
that oh why you saying that problem we
have to advise the personal setup says
you either enjoy good and forbid even if
you do not allow send down a calamity
even if you appreciated me you'll be
rejected from you so we need to enjoin
good and forbid evil obviously with
wisdom it's not just here I'm enjoying
every turn the time no there's go back
to our teachers but this is very
important that we lose you know you're
most likely watching this that we
distinguish between advice even if it's
done in a public forum because it's the
Sinister in public it has to be
addressed public that we should be
careful you know but we're not condoning
that the HBO's receiving things the
filth of the understanding of you know
anything to its details yes or why yes
it's very detailed and it's a issue of
weighing up between harms and benefits
Masada and my first yes it comes from
the hadith absurd in Holden Asahi Muslim
now anyway whomsoever sees me evil
introduces hand if not with his tongue
and there's a whole understanding many
many many books reasonableness is you've
standalone books it also even take me
alone
so didn't he say that for example
enjoying a good he was gonna bring great
huh don't do it absolutely this is a
message to every single person who runs
one of those Islamic Twitter profiles or
Muslim YouTube channels or Muslim pages
who just instead of supporting your
brothers and sisters who you feed even
something wrong you push us down I
assume the best I don't think if he is
talking about us like for example s
forces asked here he's misunderstood our
message again because most of you is
that we've done with advice but not
essentially comes from original point
yet we cannot distinguish however those
who have called them names call them
names I'm talking about literally
quoting the main do these guys are
likely I'm sorry I told you something
right yeah number two something
okay this if we assume that Islam is
true because Muslims right and amen amen
in my analogy here is going to be
symbolic to analogous to health yeah
physic well yeah if you see someone's
like for instance a very popular person
on YouTube who's got very big following
and they're giving wrong medical advice
in fact the advice that they're giving
all the things that they're telling
people to do are against your health and
people are following for example saying
okay have this much sugar this smoke
this would be is now doctors and other
people that are watching this will be
thinking okay well let us come in and
you know rescue people's health because
otherwise people are going to be
consuming these things and we know that
people are consuming eating and go their
health is gonna deteriorate if that is
analogous to the spiritual state of
human beings then there has to be some
kind of counter narrative to the wild
call the liberal Islam and why I mean by
that that's that's
new thing now that's being invented and
I'll be honest with you I think these
two verses I'll be also but I think
these two individuals are proponents of
it yeah I believe that they're I'm not
gonna mince my words ensure that they
are proponents of it it's the idea that
and to hold my letters or you are free
to do everyone so long as you don't have
any address Mills principle thrown into
the Islamic discourse into a hodgepodge
of ideas envy that frankly bro I think
that that needs to be deconstructed and
Muslims are following this and thinking
that is the pseudo Islamic science Islam
is clear there are certain things which
are Hadad and certain things which are
haram louder when you say clear you mean
yes handily that's clear in the sense
that which has consensus is clear yes
and now which may be its point of
disagreement a valid point of this
opinion those doctors they are coming
out they're out of care not only for
yourself but the general mass that you
might be unintentionally guiding to the
wrong path because the Nosler has great
time exactly so we should benefit so we
should not look at these doctors and I'm
not talking if these doctors came waving
over and they started install to you
this time moving 100% yes why I didn't
show you but if they're coming with the
advice and to turn that advice into your
Haram police at this time that's
unacceptable to what that means is I
have this life let me be we can't it
doesn't work like that if we know what
why did certain other people in the old
nations fed into this even this policy
that for example Bani Israel when it
came to the matter of the Sabbath they
should have not been doing it and what
is the Scala see there was those who did
not listen and there was those who did
listen and those who were silent the
scholars say the ones who were standing
would would join the ones in the
Hellfire with the ones who did it why
because they looked and they were silent
man we can't be silent so the thing is
take our advice as advice brother like
believe me I'll say this from above my
heart I don't do this for money to be
like we don't do this one like let's
make one it's not about this we
genuinely care about our brothers and
sis as much as you're passionate you
never go that one goal is to get the
youth to practice their religion and
this is the reason actually start our
whole organization but not let's not
let's not be little you know
I don't see as a kind of glue but you
know something out something any few
schoolers and there's a very profound
statements like this whole concept is
from meson Dean it is literally the
scale of the religion in the scale of
the religion why we weighed the good and
the world and that's why this other face
back on the string if you look now
everything is all Happy Days whenever
you wanna come with she runs one of
those like jab and stuff whatever she
said when I Joe when I first called
myself little cutter before I even yeah
she tweeted and she said this is new to
avocado brother I am convinced that Arab
parents don't know how to raise men yeah
I went to my mom and I said who does she
think she is cannot let me talk about me
but to say that you you raise the
perfect son and because of that and
because I didn't go on there because I
just trusted it my in man my strength is
stronger than ever
she said religion specifically seems
like a really bothers him back to the
extent that he had to go to his mom and
see like what's she trying to say where
does this come from that what advice
would you give to prophecy with these
negative comments are being thrown at
you on a daily basis and it really gets
to him I don't know what I would present
buzzer so um what I wanted to say is
that if we look at this side the studies
that have been done on social media
there's lots of studies that have been
done there's our tutorial on it but I'm
not gonna go into it in detail but the
idea is this social media usage the more
generally speaking the more social media
you're on and the more hours you're on
it the more your lectures have
depression
or lack of sleep or all of these things
which are very negative yeah so as
someone who's braced their lives we
spend a lot of time on social media as
well one thing I try and do and this is
advice to myself yeah one thing I try
and do and a lot of people been advising
me to jail overnight because I try and
keep my distance social media now you
know is I try and save this space in my
day for social media my week a time and
a place for it and that's what not to
attach myself to achieve much because
the thing is if you do go into this
virtual reality this virtual reality is
gonna cause you to be depressed he's
gonna cause you to be anxious it's gonna
give you a virtual finger dementia
fingers really absolutely so why I would
say is that there's a beautiful honey
for the house in addition to what you've
mentioned yeah yeah is there to do Nate
your head Luke witness your head baccala
or is heavy mind a mess your hope in
this that is the witness in the heavy
person I know is for you the hadith
basically says that you know leave off
leave off what the world has to offer
and Allah will love you
so be aesthetic in the world and Allah
will love you leave our for the people
have and the people will love you in
other words and this is the reality of
capitalism guys yeah and Suzy in
particular if you're watching this yeah
capitalism is a system which if you go
into here and you start competing in the
framework of capitalism whether it's on
social media whether it's on in the
economic in in the market in a
marketplace or other than that your
happiness is going to be linked to your
success and there will always be someone
more successful than you and so this is
just as you'll never be satiated and as
a resolve that you will never be fully
satisfied you know so I was gonna say is
that gone back to the hadith yeah I know
yeah I heard about that he's left
associated what I was gonna say was that
that approach is a better rule Pro I'm
saying leave social media I'm saying now
find a meaningful social media in your
life it's gotta be it's got to transfer
and the ego centric model isn't right
because if if the meaning for social
media if the main reason is just to
promote yourself it's not a good enough
reason purpose it has to have a happen
where is why we're on social media
Angela it's because we're trying to
advance the meaning of life - people
wanna promote the meaning of life -
people do believe is to be submissive
yeah to Allah to be - to follow up
because that is the purpose of life
we haven't created the jinn he will
bring deception that they may worship we
believe that that is the meaning of one
God not three or now and Anil Anil or
whatever may be one God we believe that
all the prophets came with yes that's
what we're trying to promote to the
people so our message hopefully yeah
transcends our being that's why going
back to where that's a half wound along
with Elohim I don't fear any blame of
different well they often win today they
don't fear the blame of the blamers
so if if you're doing it for
transcendent purpose whatever reason you
were wherever you are gonna be doing now
yeah whatever you gonna be doing now if
there's a backlash that backlashes
is expected number one and number two is
in the context of I don't care because
I'm doing what my purpose of life
exactly you know that's fing I'm gonna
be a movie about a station move that
will brother Adam sorry when we advised
him we got a massive backlash at the
beginning with it we got massive
backlash and at the end it kind of you
know people apologize etc but those back
let's not be honest you it didn't get me
I was upset to see that youngsters are
thinking this way but the whole point
was in shock I was thinking look I'm
challenges for the right reasons so what
you're dealing is irrelevant it doesn't
mean nothing because I know why I'm
doing this inshallah and what you're
attacking me form is irrelevant
so that's what I would say Barbara one
liberal advanced form of gives you is
the Edison render to me my surface
action reminds me of myself as much as I
care just 10% of me caring about what
others think about me if I just use 10%
of them care and for to myself how would
I love to see me I think our whole life
in a whole direction will change if you
fix your face with Allah Allah will fix
a face with the people do not look then
ever gonna be happy will be I'm telling
you never ever ever never never will get
is simple and you know why this may be a
lot to show you the only one that's not
gonna let you down is the one who
created you O mankind be your mommy your
daddy with riches they love you by swept
on our life they said to your mom is dad
go in the grave instead of your son no
that's where the guys need to realize
that's why Allah says only with the
remember you're not blue hearts find
peace we are programmed your song you
feed your body before the commercial you
training this food you give you're
looking after your body you see
nutrition my muscles need this in these
rest in his protein in his this Bravo
Bangla your soul your heart is the same
same your heart is yearning for Allah
with me feed it I'm not saying you buy
me some gym money is rejected it's
another one it caused a no on a woman I
don't wanna it's rejecting it it's
calling for Allah will give you the room
food I don't know I haven't seen for a
long time but what was gonna say was
that one one one tip if he just promotes
a charity project he does philanthropy I
mean he doesn't do that I don't know but
if he does that imagine if he does that
consistently over a span of imagine how
much money the man can raise you know
that's meaningful that's transcendent
that's more than the egocentric model
that's when the man who starts to feel
you know like what I'm doing is more
valuable in actually you know a there's
a specific shot one one little boy
approaches them an EP goes I'm gonna pay
for your whole just uni fee just if he
goes if he goes down that really
personal worship that they do in
addition to that which Allah wants from
you from your compulsory because it's
these additional acts of murder that
will strengthen you it's not providing
nutrition to your soul so when those
tests come eventually and after the love
they don't come to come you all ready
for it
because when the man is high you need to
prepare what is going to be low you need
to get ready it's that you go into the
jungle buffer one point I'm gonna hit
the jungle let me get rid you let me get
my fat everything ready and that's how
we need to think so basically it doesn't
mean anything else one fish is good know
how much receive every month that a lot
small not equally man away from you
again be a reminder to all of us you
know that we always ask for badges or
showing up well I guess you know yeah
well physician he retook the Shahadah
Chama
I hope Allah keeps him firm and wonders
I'll give you watching this go on rock
for watching I would say you know this
is the perfect time for you to say you
know what just so now cope from home run
[ __ ]
trust me you know reconnect to the words
from our sisters we're gonna finish off
by watching him taking on inshallah on
the fullscreen Marrakesh you guys from
from the house as you know the house
more reaction videos and more guests and
other appearances we have an institute
keep an eye on each other
take care